- So we saw some other
work you did earlier
in lockdown and well, let's watch
(upbeat music)
- Captain's log.
It has been 500 spaces since captain,
our captain and my lover went to receive
our search has led us to the
Galatia quadrant with Lord
and Sandra are
investigating the last-known
whereabouts of captain,
the fair employment.
Quiz'.
(upbeat music)
- My God.
I really wish I could have
been in lockdown with you.
Cause you're so fun.
That was amazing.
The microwave was my favorite part.
So advanced, what is that?
What's that show?
- So Kevin and Ross mains
two guys in Scotland,
they sort of wrote and edited
this and then my really
good friend, Steven Cree,
who was an Outlander with me
he roped a lot of us into this
thing and it was just like
we were all in lockdown and
nobody was doing anything.
So it was like, do you wanna
do something really silly
and really fun?
And it was like, of course.
- Absolutely.
- Let's do it.
Let's do our own makeup.
Let's use kitchen utensils.
Let's have a show, but
it was like everyone
from James McAvoy, Florence
Pugh, like we, you know,
we had a stellar cast.
- A-game.
- Yeah, It was like A-listers on that.
- What's the name? Is it star?
- Star force.
- Star force, of course.
- There is no copyright
right fringing on anybody.
I'm sure actually now that
people are actually seeing this
we might have to give some props to some
of the footage, they've
stolen from other places,
but you know, that's all good.
- But it's fine.
It was COVID, it was a pandemic.
Thank you so much, Katrina.
I'm such a fan and you're so lovely.
- Thank you, such a pleasure.
- Congrats on your little one.
- Oh, thank you.
- That's so exciting,
It's an exciting time.